poverty hurts I mean I don't like it and
I don't like that our academic system is
so corrupt so it's one of the most
important messages I have onor is that
failure should inspire you to get
smarter don't let failure ever stop you
you know use your brain use your
creativity and unfortunately our school
system says if you if you fail you're
stupid that is not true so the lesson to
young people is don't take a job for the
money take a job for what you're
learning in school they compensate for
Risk by telling you memorize the right
answer so in other words these kids
leave young people like you leave school
think oh if I know the right answers
then there's no risk and it drives old
guys like me crazy you know we learn
from our mistakes mistakes are
opportunities to get smarter be humble
and take a look at something you know
Millennials are the most highly educated
they know all the answers but they're
afraid of doing
anything